salut je m'appelle Fabien olicard dans
ce format nous faisons un focus sur un
point en particulier du cerveau dans les
commentaires des épisodes précédents
vous nous avez proposé de parler de
l'impact du langage sur le cerveau c'est
le sujet du jour bienvenue dans matière
grise
[Musique]
dans cet épisode vous allez vivre 4
expériences expériences une association
d'idées expérience 2 lui éblouissant
expérience 3 c'est à VOUS expérience 4
langue de bois ou de carton le tout avec
la présence très apprécié de Éléonore
Coste
[Musique]
le langage il est partout tout le temps
même dans votre tête vous subocalisez
c'est comme ça qu'on appelle le fait de
parler dans sa tête avec sa petite voix
intérieure notre pensée étant associatif
il était essentiel que l'être humain
puisse qualifier étiqueter nommer les
choses et pas seulement pour communiquer
avec les autres mais aussi pour
communiquer avec lui-même le langage est
organisé dans les neurones par
association notre cerveau est composé de
68 à 100 milliards de neurones chaque
neurone peut avoir jusqu'à 100 000
connexions avec d'autres neurones ainsi
quand je vous dis le mot pomme vous
pensez à une pomme oui évidemment mais
vous voyez une pomme et vous pensez sans
vous en rendre compte à pommier à fruits
à Apple si vous avez appris le terme en
anglais à Manzana pour l'espagnol et
toute une série de mots et de concepts
qui rebondissent les uns sur les autres
c'est d'ailleurs le principe du
brainstorming mais saviez-vous que
parfois la connexion n'est établie que
dans un seul sens du besoin né la
fonction et les jonctions entre les mots
dans votre esprit n'est pas toujours en
aller on appelle ça la connaissance
rétrospective
on parle donc du langage et le langage
il fonctionne dans le cerveau par
association d'idées en fait notre
cerveau comme le C Loïc qui m'a entendu
un milliard de fois le dire dans ma
ville le cerveau il est associatif et
comparatif donc il associe les idées il
associe les informations et sur chaque
neurone tu as des Synaps qui vont se
connecter à d'autres neurones tu en as
jusqu'à 100 000 par neurones 100.000
connexions donc c'est beaucoup sachant
que à peu près 100 milliards de neurones
fait le calcul c'est trop voilà
n'interroge pas moi j'ai pas de temps
révisé que ça et là je vais te parler
d'un truc qui est formidable qui
s'appelle le biais de connaissance
rétrospectif tu as déjà vécu ça c'est
quand tu crois que tu sais quelque chose
alors qu'en fait tu le savais pas
exemple concret le trivial Pursuit
c'est pas à toi de jouer il y a
quelqu'un qui ont posé une question et
quand on donne la réponse parce que il
ou elle a pas trouvé toi tu fais mais
oui c'était facile je savais et
bizarrement
tu le savais vraiment mais ça c'est que
tu crois en réalité les informations
elles sont déposées dans ton cerveau
elles sont pas toujours bien connectées
dans le bon sens et je vais te faire un
exemple concret je te pose une question
tu as trois secondes pour y réfléchir et
tu me dois dire sincèrement ta réponse
après tu vas penser s'il te plaît à
trois villes australiennes
et là où tu vas constater le billet de
connaissance rétrospective c'est imagine
maintenant sincèrement si j'avais
commencé l'expérience une en disant dis
donc Eleonore est-ce que tu savais que
Canberra Melbourne et Sydney ce sont des
villes australiennes
mais la première c'est en fait c'est
horrible cette émission je vais vraiment
passer pour une conne pas du tout pas du
tout en fait tu représentes ceux qui
découvrent le sujet et tu représentes
moi avant de travailler sur le sujet
aussi je n'en savais pas plus que toi là
je fais le malin parce que j'ai des
fiches et que j'ai fait des recherches
tu vois en fait de la même manière c'est
comme si je t'avais dit donc Christophe
Colomb a découvert l'Amérique en 1492 il
y avait trois bateaux c'était la ligne à
la pénitale à la Santa Maria tu as déjà
entendu parler de tout ça forte chance
que tu m'as dit oui tout ça je le sais
mais en fait en réalité si je t'avais
dit c'est en quelle année quel est le
nom des bateaux tu le sais pas à ce
moment là en fait ce sont des
informations qui se plaquent quelque
part dans ton cerveau et elle se
connecte mal aux autres donc tu les
trouves dans un sens si on te dit Sydney
tu penses à Australie tout de suite mais
si on te dit Australie tu penses pas à
Sidney tout de suite en fait
l'aller-retour est pas forcément bien
connecté tu vois ce que je veux dire
parce que si tu l'avais
un contrat de confiance on a fait comme
ça avec notre sang c'est sûr en fait il
y a une manière de bien fixer les
informations c'est les émotions donc si
on met une émotion particulière du style
ah d'accord et bien ça ça va se fixer
beaucoup plus longtemps démonstration
tout de suite est-ce que tu sais
pourquoi on dit les teenagers en anglais
pourquoi on est dans l'eau on appelle
les jeunes les teenagers
pour qu'on disait un teenager j'ai fait
mais bien sûr et se met bien sûr qu'il y
a une émotion très forte va faire que
toute ma vie je vais m'en souvenir et
que j'aurais envie de le raconter à tout
le monde tu vois
est-ce que tu sais compter en anglais
ouais un peu alors compte à partir de 10
elle vient de le faire elle a fait le
savais pas que les mots
incroyable
et tu vois ce que tu indives l'émotion
positive ça fait que ça va connecter
dans tous les sens c'est-à-dire à chaque
fois que tu entendras compter en anglais
tu vas penser à ça à cette histoire à
chaque fois que tu entendras tin ou
teenager tu vas penser à ça et même plus
que ça ça s'est connecté du coup à
adolescent en français donc dès que tu
penseras adolescent qu'on dira c'est un
truc d'adolescente il y a en fait est-ce
que tu sais pourquoi en anglais on dit
ça et surtout je vais enfin réussir à
compter à mettre le in à la fin
j'ai toujours un doute après
mais là je suis sûr vous me re
demanderez
les cerveaux c'est mon métier
[Musique]
méfiez-vous maintenant de la
connaissance rétrospective vous voyez
une information mais comme votre cerveau
connaît déjà chaque bout de
l'information il considère que vous
n'avez pas à porter votre attention
dessus ce qui empêche le maillage entre
les neurones qui vous permet de
continuer à associer les mots les uns
aux autres dans votre esprit maintenant
c'est avec un langage simple que je vous
annonce que la vidéo d'aujourd'hui est
sponsorisée par moi-même et là vous vous
dites de quoi il fait une auto promo
normal en fait il fait pas de mise en
scène il fait pas de trucs comme ça mais
il y a un truc important c'est parce que
je veux vous rappeler nous sommes le 12
septembre qu'à partir du 18 octobre je
suis au Palais des Glaces ça fait 7 ans
que j'ai pas fait de spectacles en
exploitation longue à Paris et bien là
pour le nouveau spectacle archétype ce
sera le cas et ça va être très cool et
après la tournée partira en janvier mais
si vous voulez venir déjà voir ça dans
les premières c'est à Paris que ça se
passe au Palais des Glaces mon petit
pote venez ça va être très cool c'est
parce que là on parle on dit bonjour
mais le Palais des Glaces oui moi
j'aimerais savoir ce que ça va rendre en
fait je te fais voir
[Rires]
si
beaucoup d'ici vous étiez pas venu ce
serait vachement moins bien c'est le
spectacle s'appelle archétype quelle est
votre prénom ragondin ragondin waouh ça
reviendra à la mode non ça c'est le bug
des années 80
ici dans ma veste j'ai une enveloppe en
fait dans le spectacle dans ma base j'ai
une enveloppe ici pensez à quelque chose
ok c'est bon à quoi vous pensez à
quelque chose à quelque chose à quelque
chose je prends le truc l'englobe
j'ouvre et là il y a marqué quelque
chose mais non
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup d'être venu à ce
spectacle par les gens autour de vous
ce spectacle de
plutôt un sortant de la salle ah
d'accord laissez des critiques sur les
sites de billetterie si vous avez aimé
je m'appelle Fabien olicard et si vous
avez pas aimé je m'appelle Victor
Vincent
ciao
moi j'ai été bluffé par ce spectacle et
puis cette salle le palais des glaces et
le retour bon c'était pas si simple de
vous faire voir je vous mets le teaser
du spectacle dans la description comme
si vous verrez mieux ce que ça rend
c'est le Palais des Glaces c'est du 18
octobre jusqu'au 21 décembre si je dis
pas le bêtises il y a que 19
représentations vous savez quand les
gens sortent des spectacles souvent ils
laissent une critique sur les sites de
réservation en ligne donc on va écouter
la critique du spectateur qui était là
cinq sur cinq 10 sur 10 8 sur 8
spectacle vraiment enivrant c'était très
bien j'ai adoré voir Fabien olicard en
vrai à la fin il est disponible on
aurait pu faire une photo avec un chat
qui passait par contre petit bémol il
fait plus grand en vidéo vous avez
dépassé les 150 caractères monsieur
ahlala c'est gentil par contre parce
qu'on dirait mais en fait
[Musique]
les mots au-delà des concepts sont
chargés positivement et négativement ces
charges plus c'est moins influe
directement sur notre raisonnement
pourtant la même chose est décrite mais
nous pensons différemment et pourquoi
encore ces connexions entre les neurones
est-ce que ça voudrait dire que les mots
peuvent manipuler nos émotions
la réponse est oui
on va parler de concepts qui ont été
beaucoup mis en avant par franck Lepage
que vous travaillez sur le langage et
sur l'impact aussi politique du langage
donc on va même en parler plusieurs fois
là dans les expériences en gros chaque
mot a une charge émotionnelle forte et
chaque mot est lié comme je te le disais
dans l'expérience une histoire à des
images à des sons à des concepts et donc
si jamais anodin d'utiliser un mot
plutôt qu'un autre on le fait
consciemment ou pas en fait on se
manipule en permanence avec les mots et
avec le choix des mots qu'on utilise tu
vois par exemple c'est différent de dire
que qu'une personne est belle jolie ou
mignonne on a l'impression que ça veut
dire la même chose mais en fait on en
voit pas les mêmes charges ouais c'est
ça et on n'en voit pas non plus les
mêmes concepts derrière les mêmes
charges émotionnelles tu vois c'est un
truc qui me pas folle en thérapie ça
quand par exemple je sais plus l'autre
fois je dis à ma psy oui donc j'ai
acheté cette baraque pourquoi vous
utilisez le terme baraque c'est marrant
mais parce que je parle comme ça quoi
pourquoi c'est pas maison domicile
logement
[Musique]
on va faire ça dans les grandes lignes
ben tiens on va prendre un mot neutre et
on va essayer de le charger avec des
concepts différents tu vois par exemple
Loïc qui est derrière cette caméra on
pourrait dire
on pourrait dire que c'est le
réalisateur de cette vidéo ça c'est sa
fonction et c'est assez neutre mais on
pourrait le charger différemment par
exemple si je voudrais le dévaluer je
pourrais utiliser quoi pour le nommer
cadreur ou plus généralement technicien
technicien
et en vrai c'est pas fondamentalement
faux mais on sent bien qu'on met pas la
même chose derrière tu vois limite
réalisateur était presque un peu
ipan tu vois mais au final c'est un tech
là c'est les gars de la technique là qui
a derrière tu vois comment tu peux
transformer en fait ton rapport aux
choses et du coup quand tu présentes la
personne si je dis je te présente Loïc
c'est le Real des vidéos ou si je te dis
tiens ça c'est Loïc c'est un desk de
l'équipe je vais pas t'envoyer la même
importance sur cette personne dans sa
fonction dans le respect que j'y porte
et donc dans le respect que tu dois lui
porter tu vois donc c'est très important
de faire attention aux mots qu'on
utilise mais aussi de se dire tiens
quelle est l'intention derrière
l'utilisation de ce mois
on fait comment
[Rires]
un autre exemple je m'étais noté ça ça
c'est marrant je te transforme le
concept de mon émission c'est une
émission de télévision
divertissante à but sociologique filmé
en temps réel ça me concept de la télé
et suivant comment tu le nom les
missions tu vois bien que encore une
fois tout est vrai mais en fait
tu donnes en fait une couleur on a vu ça
par exemple aussi durant la guerre du
Golfe du jour au lendemain les
bombardements se sont appelés des
frappes chirurgicales OK et c'était la
même chose c'est des avions qui larguent
des bombes au-dessus d'un endroit en
espérant que ça tombe au bon endroit tu
vois mais sauf que quand je t'ai dit le
mot frappe chirurgical dans ta tête tu
as tout ton imagerie de la chirurgie et
tous les mots connexes dans ton langage
à la chirurgie à savoir la précision tu
vois la rigueur même sauver des vies
tous ces concepts là et donc du coup le
fait qu'on utilise plus bombardement toi
dans le fond tu sais que c'est la même
chose et pourtant dans tes émotions tu
vas regarder un autre crédit parce que
tu dis non mais c'est chirurgical c'est
déjà tu vois ça dans ta tête tu vois tu
vois la précision du truc tu vois et
c'est comme ça qu'on tienne le langage
c'est pour ça aussi qu'on a changé des
mots comme redoublement à l'école
la réussite différée
donc en fait on réussit mais un peu plus
tard
vachement mieux en fait du coup parce
que du coup tu as pas redoublée
plus tard c'est juste ça va venir quoi
pensez-y aussi il y a plein d'exemples
qui vous viendront en tête de
l'utilisation des mots dans le marketing
et par les politiques qui sont quand
même très manipulant parce que tu vas
véhiculer un concept directement par le
mot que tu emploies ou pas quoi tu vois
donc c'est toujours faire attention à ça
parce que le langage est toujours en
fait il est jamais neutre il est
toujours chargé d'émotion et chargé
d'image
utilise vachement ça enfin pervers
narcissique c'est le langage est très au
centre de leur de leur technique
[Musique]
d'ailleurs le cerveau n'a pas de
négation dans sa compréhension du
langage dire que dans ton système de
pensée la négation est pas comprise dans
ton inconscient en fait
d'où le fait d'utiliser les bons mots
c'est pour ça que il faut penser par
exemple je veux avoir un meilleur
salaire plutôt que de penser je ne veux
plus être pauvre parce que je ne peux
plus être pauvre tu conceptualise le mot
pauvre plutôt de conceptualiser le
salaire ou le fait de d'avoir plus de
choses tu vois il faut toujours même
quand tu discutes avec quelqu'un
d'ailleurs éviter d'utiliser la négation
parce que lui-même va moins bien la
conceptualiser au final quoi tu vois
tout ce que je donne ça t'intéresse
nous commençons à entrevoir que les mots
ne sont pas aussi neutres que l'on
imaginait
comment on les emploie parfois il suffit
même d'utiliser une forme de phrase
plutôt qu'une autre pour avoir un effet
de cadrage il y a d'ailleurs une
excellente étude qui a été faite par
Daniel kadman qui s'appelle l'effet de
cadrage ou en présentant deux
possibilités face à un problème à deux
groupes de personnes avec les mêmes
données on obtenait des réponses
différentes pour vous la faire très
rapidement on imaginait une pandémie
bien avant le covid pourtant et les
groupes avaient deux moyens de guérir
les 600 personnes qui étaient devant eux
l'option numéro une était présentée au
premier groupe comme pouvant sauver 200
personnes et l'option numéro une était
présentée au deuxième groupe comme
allant tué 400 personnes c'était
pourtant la même chose mais la donnée
mise en avant changez l'émotionnel si
vous voulez en savoir plus sur
l'expérience de cane man je vous invite
à regarder le matière grise précédent
que je vous mettrai dans la description
[Musique]
tout à l'heure nous verrons un grand
exemple de détournement de langage en
faisant une battle de langue de bois
mais juste avant voyons comment vous
allez vous en sortir avec ces questions
oui parce que c'est à vous
[Musique]
c'est parti pour le c'est à VOUS tu vas
donner tes réponses mais on attend vos
réponses dans les commentaires et
dites-nous sincèrement je vois ce qui
triche question une c'est une petite
énigme le lien entre toutes ces énigmes
c'est bien sûr le langage ok
j'apparais quand l'été arrive et je
reviens à la fin de l'automne on me voit
aussi au milieu de l'hiver mais qui
suis-je je répète
on te voit tout début de l'émission bien
sûr on le on le voit par deux fois en
toi non trois fois on le voit par trois
fois en elle
mais qu'est-ce que c'est on le voit là
en tout cas si on parle de ton prénom
à la fin de l'automne au milieu de
l'hiver
en parlant d'engagement écoute cette
phrase engage le jeu que je le gagne
c'est une phrase à une particularité de
langage que j'adore est-ce que tu seras
trouver laquelle engage le jeu que je le
gagne
double sens engage de jeu engage le jeu
engage le jeu j'ai eu x que je le gagne
c'est pas dans son sens c'est purement
architectural engage le jeu que je le
gagne si je le lis à l'envers ça fait
engage le jeu que je le gagne en fait
c'est une phrase voilà comment tu dis
une phrase
c'est un mot que tu lis dans de gauche à
droite ou de droite à gauche comme
ténètes le mot tenette pour le filet de
net d'ailleurs je l'ai pas vu encore
il y a une histoire comme ça des fois
d'aller-retour dans la lecture des
choses troisième question attention
c'est une énigme le fils de cet homme
est le père de mon fils
pourtant je ne suis pas une femme
comment c'est possible le fils de cet
homme est le père de mon fils
pourtant je ne suis pas une femme alors
le fils de cet homme donc on a un homme
il y a son fils et donc ce gars-là c'est
le père d'un autre enfant et c'est le
père quand même de l'enfant de la
personne qui est en train de parler mais
la personne de pas qui est en train de
parler n'est pas une femme du coup
comment ça c'est possible en fait en
gros c'est qui parle
[Rires]
tu vois ça faisait longtemps en ce
moment
[Musique]
tu débutes
donc le fils de cet homme et le père de
mon fils et moi je ne suis pas une femme
donc si je ne suis pas une femme a
priori je suis un homme en tout cas mon
énigme et binaire et donc si je suis un
homme il y a une grande chance que je
sois le père de cet enfant donc en fait
le fils de cet homme c'est moi et moi je
suis le père de mon fils c'est juste le
protagoniste qui parle vous pouvez lui
commander à Hubert elle en a marre
c'était juste ça et en fait là ça
renvoie au truc du langage c'est à dire
à partir du moment où on parle pas de on
parle de soi la troisième personne en
disant cet homme est le père de mon fils
en fait c'est tellement inhabituel dans
notre langage que c'est en vrai
inconcevable qu'on imagine qu'on est en
train que c'est la personne qui parle
d'elle-même en fait parce que le
département son truc alors que dans la
logique dans une certaine logique
mathématique c'est c'est sûr c'est la
seule réponse possible mais on n'arrive
même pas d'envisager en fait parce que
c'est pas dans notre forme de langage
habituel c'est ça qu'on voulait
démontrer donc c'est normal en cuisine
où est-ce qu'on peut trouver des melocos
des meloco c'est ma question
[Rires]
est-ce qu'on peut trouver des mélochos
est-ce que c'est pas
le langage donc ça peut pas être une
réponse genre dans le beurre
[Rires]
c'est quand la dernière fois que tu as
mangé des locaux sachant que la réponse
ne peut pas être jamais car je sais que
tu en as déjà mangé qu'il l'a lever la
main
pourquoi tu l'as
en plus
ça doit être un truc
parce que sinon je dirais le Mel local
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
et pareil en fait
j'adore ces trucs
pour les refaire ce soir
et si tu sors une vidéo là dessus assez
tôt la mienne sera pas sortie
et donc dès qu'on utilise en fait des
associations de mots qui ont une espèce
de sonorité musicale et qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude de mettre ensemble on n'est
pas capable de les reconnaître donc le
langage les conceptuels mais il passe
aussi par la musicalité et dès qu'on te
on te sort du truc et qu'on te change la
prosodie c'est-à-dire qu'on accélère par
exemple l'association de deux mots tu as
l'impression que c'est un nouveau mot tu
en aurais il le reconnaît pas et elle
voit un nouveau mot dans la tête c'est
une fin d'expérience 3 oui moi
bien sûr pour la première fois en 18
épisodes de matière grise je vis une
expérience dont je ne sais rien puisque
Chris vient de nous dire je peux vous
faire faire un truc donc on va faire une
sorte de dictée c'est ça Chris une
dictée ok tu copies
au moins 20 fautes
mais si tu nous donnes des noms des
médicaments frérot c'est une phrase très
simple ok à l'ombre d'un grand chêne
voler une Estelle attends tu vas trop
vite
à l'ombre d'un grand chêne est une
Estelle si voler tunnels mais navenès
alors à l'ombre d'un grand chêne volet
c'est quoi la suite si vous les tunnels
tout à fait dire quelque chose
si je fais une faute je te paye un resto
tu la connaissais déjà ou pas
bon écoute moi j'ai fait n'importe quoi
voilà tu as gagné moi j'ai fait
n'importe quoi c'est même pas français
volé une Estelle
du prénom Estelle
si voler une s mais n'avaites et bien
écoute je te laisse regarder mon mon
texte où je trouvais cette histoire
assez simple à l'ombre d'un grand chêne
vos laitue mais cela
mais parce que comme on était dans le
délire des meloco et tout j'ai compris
si vous les tunnels mais n'avezness
la purée pas autant mais si tu dirais
ici si vous voulez tunnels mais n'avait
s à l'ombre
il était énorme celui-ci
vous m'avez saoulé avec votre expérience
3 et tu vas voir que l'expérience 4 est
très intéressante aussi parce qu'on va
parler de langue de bois formidable
pensez c'est parler pour reprendre des
gueules c'est dans les mots que nous
pensons mais sans le langage peut-il y
avoir une pensée pure sans parole il y a
forcément un jour dans l'humanité ou
notre pensée a précédé notre parole mais
est-ce que c'était vraiment la même
pensée comme vous le voyez nous avons
encore beaucoup beaucoup de choses à
découvrir sur notre langage et la place
qu'il prend dans notre espèce
aujourd'hui encore beaucoup de
découvertes restent à faire dans notre
cerveau concernant le langage par contre
on sait qu'on peut parler pour ne rien
dire tout en faisant croire que notre
pensée est construite et ça on va le
voir tout de suite
[Musique]
vous l'avez compris les mots
représentent donc des concepts que
parfois notre esprit ne prend même plus
la peine d'analyser en détail d'ailleurs
plus on répète un mot et plus il perd de
sa puissance émotionnelle ou de son sens
profond dans mon équipe de spectacles
mon régisseur lumière s'appelle Diablo
au fur et à mesure des années l'image
qu'on a quand on l'appelle en disant
Diablo n'a plus aucun lien avec le
diable ou l'enfer c'est aussi la flopée
des mots qui permet ce qu'on appelle la
langue de bois l'art de faire des
discours conventionnels et stéréotypés
ça vous rappelle quelque chose de proche
là de nous c'est normal
pour finaliser cette vidéo sur le
langage on va parler du pire langage qui
existe qui est très présent la langue de
bois on va on va parler de ça parce que
c'est une forme de langage incroyable ou
des gens peuvent parler des heures et tu
as l'impression qu'ils disent quelque
chose et tu vois et tout le monde est OK
pour se dire il a dit quelque chose en
fait et la seule chose qui compte c'est
les intentions qui mettent dedans et en
fait tu te réfère qu'aux intentions et
je vais le prouver aujourd'hui tu vas
être mon adversaire politique tu n'as
rien à défendre comme position tu vas
juste me poser des questions c'est pas
moi qui ai inventé ce qu'on va faire là
c'est franck Lepage qu'un militant qui
est issu de l'éducation populaire et il
a fait des conférences qu'il a appelé
les conférences gesticulées je vous
invite à les regarder et dans une de ces
conférences il fait ce qu'on va faire il
a pris quelques concepts très simples
contrat développement projet solidarité
participation mondialisation partenariat
lien social proximité on sent que ça
veut dire quelque chose tout ça mais
déjà de base on sait pas trop ce que ça
veut dire donc il y a tous ces cartons
là je vais les prendre je vais les
mélanger c'est pas exactement les mots
qu'il y a et je sais pas dans quel ordre
c'est je fais un vrai mélange
comme franck Lepage le faisait
sacré froid sacré Franqui non non mais
c'est un génie d'avoir pensé à faire ça
et toi tu vas me poser une question tu
te dis que je suis vraiment candidat au
présidentiel et où tu me poses une
question ou tu m'attaques sur un sujet
tu vois mais comme si tu étais une
politiqueienne qui voulait mettre à mal
sur quelque chose me mettre en faiblesse
et tu voulais que je réponde à quelque
chose donc je t'écoute alors comment
concrètement vous vous allez nous faire
sortir de cette crise écologique et avec
des réponses très concrètes et un
programme très clair et en supposant que
j'ai 5 ans bien sûr vous parlez d'un
programme clair et je pense que quand on
parle d'écologie on parle d'abord de
lien social parce que l'écologie c'est
complètement transversale ça nécessite
qu'on commence par faire un diagnostic
partagé de nos actions à tous au
quotidien et qu'on établisse une sorte
de contrat entre nous dans la vraie
volonté de changer des choses et c'est
comme ça qu'on fera un programme
interculturel qui permettra de changer
des choses dans notre pays que ce soit
au niveau local c'est à dire à l'échelle
de l'individu ou que ce soit dans le
développement du National qui représente
quand même toute l'industrie et les
habitants et c'est comme ça qu'on pourra
avoir un vrai projet écologique quelque
chose de viable dans une forme de
solidarité et non pas dans un entre soi
qu'on voit depuis des années il faut
amener les gens à avoir une
participation à l'écologie et ne pas
attendre que des choses de l'état de
décentraliser un petit peu cette
décision de l'état de vouloir changer
des choses c'est vraiment à l'échelle de
la mondealisation qu'on pourra tous se
mettre d'accord on parle du local et on
augmente au national et au mondial dans
un partenariat collectif à l'échelle
mondiale pour se dire non on veut plus
ça pour notre planète on veut que la
citoyenneté soit elle-même écologique et
non pas que l'écologie appelle à la
citoyenneté et ce seront les habitants
de chaque ville de chaque quartier qui
seront les acteurs de ce changement là
pour que à proximité de leur habitation
de leur travail et de leurs enfants on
puisse avoir une démocratie écologique
c'est horrible c'est horrible j'ai
répondu à ta question j'ai répondu c'est
terrible parce que du coup là ouais tu
viens de démontrer de les coulisses de
ce qui fait que je déteste la politique
c'est tout ce que je veux
tous et c'est dingue j'ai lu les
concepts
pas du tout répondu à votre question
d'un mec qui voulait
un changement merci d'avoir participé à
ces matières grises et merci de m'avoir
permis de démontrer que l'importance du
langage comme on l'a vu dans les deux
premières expériences et de montrer
aussi le pire qu'on pouvait en faire
c'est à dire ça faites attention quand
vous vous dites à la fin est-ce que je
peux résumer sa pensée en une phrase si
la réponse est non c'était de la langue
de bois en fait c'est aussi clair que ça
quoi tu vois tu peux pas résumer
facilement ce que la personne vient de
te dire pendant 10 minutes c'est qu'il y
avait un vrai problème quelque part je
te donne les cartons
dans ta tu pourras y répondre comme ça
étonnant de boire à quel point le
langage vers balle précis qui est censé
décrire des choses concrètes est
utilisée pour ne pas dire grand chose si
l'on associe cela aux matières grises
sur le non-verbal on peut déduire que
les formes de langage creux ne sont
qu'un terrain de proposer qui vont
servir de support au nom verbal de la
personne qui parle j'aimerais rajouter
le fait que l'on peut changer le sens
des mots avec nos intonations par
exemple ce qui permet entre autres
l'ironie à l'oral comme à l'écrit
l'écrivain Michel Antoine Burnier disait
d'ailleurs les mots ont un sens mais si
on les met entre guillemets on parvient
à les troublés merci à tous les
participants à toute l'équipe Sherlocks
mind et updated à la production merci à
Loïc à la réalisation avec toute son
équipe et bien sûr à Eleonor Coste
n'hésitez pas à découvrir ses vidéos je
vous mets des liens dans la description
le prochain épisode de matière grise
sera publié le mois prochain il va
parler de la différence qu'il y a entre
croire et savoir vous pouvez vous
abonner gratuitement à cette chaîne
Youtube si cette série vous plaît et
vous avez également les 17 épisodes
précédent de matière grise dans la
description alors pensez-vous comprendre
réellement le sens des mots pensez-vous
qu'un simple mot pourrait influencer
votre pensée vous serez tous là bien
plus dans les prochains épisodes de
matière grise à très bientôt Ciao
[Musique]